you think cuz I went to rehab I stayed
clean me ain't that the point now well
the world's coming to an end and I
haven't even graduated high school yet
I'm dr. Ali Mattu cognitive behavioral
therapist and I'm here today in
collaboration with HBO to offer my take
on themes of mental health in their
shows today we'll talk about substance
use and how can affect behavior through
the lens of ruh in euphoria if I could
be a different person that is you I
would
euphoria is one of the most honest
representations of substance use
problems I've seen rude talks about her
history with grief with a learning
disability and anxiety option I can
breathe I gave the liquid valium and I
found a way to live some people might be
vulnerable to developing problems with
substances because they're experiencing
underlying mental illness I don't know
what type of fucked-up [ __ ] you got
going inside you I don't know how to
help but I could tell you one thing this
drug [ __ ]
it's not the answer the stereotype that
exists in our country is certain people
are addicts and will always be addicts
and that's just not true as we treat the
underlying mental illness substance use
can often resolve itself this is
something we can all do have compassion
and in a judgment-free way ask them how
the substance is helping them this seems
like a radical idea you'd be surprised
at how most people never get asked this
question and it opens the door it makes
it easier for them to talk about what
the substances are doing and also get
them to be open to talking about change
that's all I have for you today and
remember if you need help there are
resources available to you
I'm dr. Ali Mattu and I'll see you in
the next video
you
you